le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
la réunion compte 77 collège public géré
par le département
tous les midis 35000 demi pensionnaires
prennent leur repas dans les restaurants
scolaires et tous les midis ce sont des
kg de restes qui finissent à la poubelle
pour sensibiliser les collégiens à la
lutte contre le gaspillage
le conseil départemental a imaginé un
concours qui met en compétition
plusieurs établissements de l'île à
l'étang salé
le collège simon lucas participent au
concours ne gaspille nous avons suivi
pendant une journée les élèves et le
corps enseignant dans leur action contre
le gaspillage
[Musique]
3 kg 5 et 1 kg carences depuis quelques
jours après chaque repas
c'est le rituel de la balance théophile
et ses amis ne sont pas au régime
ce qu'ils contrôlent c'est le poids des
déchets alimentaires car la pesée des
restes c'est l'une des missions de cette
jeune brigade vont tour à tous donc nous
sommes la brigade ne gaspille c'est une
brigade qui a été inventé en début
d'année donc pour participer à un
concours
ce concours ne gaspille est organisé par
le conseil départemental 15 collèges sur
77 y participent
le but sensibiliser les jeunes
réunionnais au gaspillage alimentaire
l'enjeu pour le département c'est donc
également l'ensemble de l'équipe de la
restauration scolaire la communauté
éducative afin de diminuer vraiment de
façon significative la quantité de
déchets alimentaires chaque
établissement décide des actions qu'il
veut mener pour le concours à chaque fin
de repas infernal sélectionné quelques
semaines où on fait des pesée des
déchets restants au collège simon lucas
la brigade noga spip prend son rôle à
coeur pour rendre les gens au courant de
cette action qu'on mène et puis on a
aussi fait des affiches pour mettre dans
la cantine avec l'information voilà des
conseils que les gens soient au courant
et il faut que je donne des conseils
alors ok essaie de partager votre
dessert implication des élèves mais
aussi de tout le corps enseignant
c'est la principale adjointe de
l'établissement qui a souhaité inscrire
son collège dans cette démarche
ce sujet nous a sensibilisés c'est
quelque chose d'important parce qu'on
les joue on est là dans le cadre de
l'éducation à la citoyenneté
donc ce sont les futurs citoyens de
demain c'est une question d'éducation
mais il n'ya pas que l'enfant qui est
concerné lorsqu'on a demandé au collège
de se positionner sur le concours on a
demandé à ce que soit créée une équipe
où on va retrouver des gens de la
restauration
on va retrouver des élèves des
administratifs mais aussi des parents
parce que la formation éducation se fait
au niveau de tous les gens y compris les
les agents qui font la restauration en
premier la façon de servir la façon de
préparer la façon d'agrémenter ya le
groupement le groupement et les eaux en
cuisine les équipes l'ont bien compris
et le chef n'hésite pas à ajouter son
grain de sel pour appâter les
demi-pensionnaires
quand il arrive des gamins ans j'y suis
allée couleurs on jure c'est la quantité
on joue sur voila on joue sur le
grammage on joue on sait plus ou moins
les gamins qu'est ce qu'ils aiment et à
partir de là on essaie de d'avoir
quelque chose aussi présent pour eux
c'est en 10 mois datant envies vos noix
enfin c'est grave au jambon fromage
abord une meilleure présentation et une
meilleure connaissance des aliments pour
ne pas en laisser une miette vous
aujourd'hui à la calebasse et ses tweets
albas on allait longanis pays souvent
nous on fait on tienne brochure sur
internet on met devant au moins le gamin
il apprend le problème aujourd'hui si le
fawe pas et ne mange pas ciel de midi
les assiettes se vident les poubelles se
remplissent mais à l'heure du bilan
les résultats sont encourageants chez
total aujourd'hui on a fait 35 05
des légumes fruits et légumes essayant
légumes avec lui ce serait que après
après qu'on ait fini le
c'est cette action que ça continue et
que ça s'arrête pas parce que le projet
est fini il faudrait que seulement que
les pesées daxatou joueront même
les résultats du concours sont attendus
pour la fin du mois de juin
même si avec cette action tout le monde
est gagnant
[Musique]
le concours ne gaspille est une
initiative du département de la réunion
objectif mettre en place des actions
dans les collèges pour lutter contre le
gaspillage alimentaire 15 établissements
de l'île y participe depuis septembre
dernier dans chaque collège
un groupe d'élèves mais aussi le
personnel de restauration et le corps
enseignant doivent s'impliquer dans ses
actions une campagne de pesée des
déchets est organisée ainsi que
l'élaboration d'un menu anti gaspillage
des ateliers d'éducation à la nutrition
sont aussi dispensés pendant le concours
pour plus de renseignements ou pour
connaître le résultat du concours fin
juin rendez vous sur le site du
département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]